what is going on everybody welcome to
part 9 of the Python the three basics
tutorial series in this video what we
doing is coming back to our tic-tac-toe
game coming back to reality and
addressing the fact that when you write
a program you know you have the best
intentions but whenever you start
letting users play with your program or
other programmers use your program and
kind of build on top of it different
people think in different ways and
people start trying to use your program
in ways you didn't intend or didn't
think of and things start to go wrong
and then with the users sometimes your
users are just stupid or or they're
trying to do something or they don't
understand or you didn't explain it well
enough for them to use what you've
created the way you intended or whatever
or people just try to break your stuff
all these reasons mean we should try to
handle for errors most of time like an
example would be like when you go to
someone's website and you try to visit a
URL that doesn't exist you usually get
some sort of decently looking you know
404 page that says hey this page doesn't
exist go back home something like that
well if the programmer doesn't
specifically handle for that 404 you are
going to get a very disgusting like
black and white just 404 and it's gonna
look pretty darn bad and it's gonna
discourage people from staying on your
website and in fact most of the time if
someone gets that they're gonna bounce
off of your website the same thing is
true with your app if your app just
crashes people have very little patience
so let's talk about error handling so
probably the biggest error that's gonna
happen is somebody's going to try to
play tic-tac-toe
and gosh darn it they don't like the
idea that we started with zero they want
to play on Row three dang it so they're
gonna do that right and again right now
we're kind of hard coding things but
later we're gonna ask the user where do
you want to play they're gonna input
where they want to play so let's say
they input a three and we run it
it looks so ugly it looks so ugly now in
in sublime text this is what we see and
basically we're looking for the what's
called title cased where ever the letter
of every word is capitalized so in this
case the title is or the the error the
title case terror is index error and
officially it's actually at the end of
the error so we've been running
everything in sublime text and maybe now
would be a good moment for us to address
running things from the console the
other way you would actually run a
program is probably not in your editor
so let's go ahead and open up a console
so on you know at least on Linux you can
right-click an open console here or open
terminal here on Windows you can just
come to the address bar up there and
just type CMD and that'll open up a
terminal right where we are and ctrl +
is not a valid
let's see properties and see if I can do
this quickly
let's go 28 ok good enough so now let's
say we want to run tutorial 9 so the way
we would do that is 1 you could type
just Python and currently that is
referencing Python 3.7 for me but if you
have multiple versions of Python by the
way quit is a built-in function and you
can exit that's just typed by default
now I just type it you could also do
like you price [ __ ] you should be able
to get away with can maybe control you
can't get out with control C so anyways
what do we do if we want to actually run
a Python program well if you want to
specify you could say PI - 3.7 if I hit
enter here it still opens up the same
version I'm on
so we could say python 3.7 and then what
do we want to run so I think it was
tutorial run tutorial 9 so we'll run
tutorial 9 and we'll actually see the
very you know this is the full trace
back it doesn't have that extra stuff
that we saw in sublime text but
basically this is the error and then it
gives us a little snippet of code that
it saw tells us in what file did we see
it in most cases
when you get an error like this the real
error that you're looking for is at the
bottom of your script if you're working
in a much larger project though
sometimes it can get buried because the
trace back literally a trace is back the
error and goes in the order that the
program ran so sometimes at the end of
your code or at the end of the trace
back it does have an error but the thing
that caused that error is sometimes
buried deep because it was a different
script that aired and then the errors
trans transgress okay continue through
until we got to your the current place
that you're working so sometimes it
won't be at the very very bottom but
this is always what you're looking for
you're just looking for that but it will
always give you the file name and then
on what line did that well here it
starts with where it occurred but then
here it also gives you line 9
specifically where did it happen so on
line 16 we made the call to modify here
so at first it says line 16 that's where
happened but then specifically on line 9
we through the index error and if you
ever get in there and you have no idea
what it means
Google it's your best friend just go to
google.com I probably just dived right
there index out of range means in gosh
it's been searched so many times that
there's even a thing up here sometimes
you'll need to add Python to the end of
what you're looking for but it's the
same result in this case or maybe if
you're using like a package and you've
got some sort of really crazy looking at
error you could add that package that
you're using with Python and by package
I mean like some sort of third party
library like tensorflow is a machine
learning library stuff like that anyway
for now I'm gonna close out of here I'm
gonna close out of here and we're going
to continue along I just wanted to show
you that normally you won't see all this
this is because I'm using sublime ok so
let's talk about how do we handle for
this error I just want to clean up that
stuff I don't know how to make go away
while I'm busy working so how can we
handle for this error well we know it
you know we first of all we can kind of
like I can predict this error is going
to happen eventually someone's going to
have
fat-fingers they're gonna accidentally
input like rather than a number maybe
they hit a letter or maybe they hit a
number too big or maybe they're just
curious to see what happens okay it's
gonna happen it's just inevitable with
this this type of program so we already
knew it was coming but how could we just
generally handle for it well there is a
try and accept statement that we can use
so we could say accept and then we'll
just say well we'll just print something
went wrong
okay so then I'll I'll change Row 2 3
again run it and then it says something
went wrong so at least this time we
handled for it we didn't do anything
about it but we handled for it and what
we could do is just ask the at this
point ask that user to do you know input
again try again something went wrong try
again basically but this isn't very
helpful necessarily to your user or to a
programmer who's actually working with
your code and like is like okay thanks
like that's not helpful to me right so
we could take it a step further and
remember it was an index error title
case index error so we can actually say
accept index error as e something went
wrong well we could say you know
something like this we could say mmm I'm
trying to think of exactly how how I
want to word it like I would say Error
error did you input row column between 0
as 0 1 or 2 that's probably the way I
would do it and then I might comma e
after that so we're just throwing in the
actual error here so we could run that
again and then now the error is error
did you input a row column as 0 1 or 2
and then or maybe make sure you input so
maybe make
make sure you input it otherwise this
sounds like you that's the mistake you
made and then and then we'll just print
out the area there something like that
okay this is actually a program I'm
gonna distribute so so I guess I am
actually distributing this program
anyways we can make this better but you
get the idea now we've handled very
specifically for an index error the only
place I can see an index error happening
in this code is here or here and the
only reason I could imagine is somebody
entered something that was not a zero
one or two okay cool so we've got that
handled for but what if darn it
what if a programmer is using this and
you know they done goofed and they pass
game board or something like that into
that function we've run it oh gosh it's
ugly
it's horrible Oh oh gosh okay so how can
we handle for that I mean as a
programmer I'm expecting you know the my
fellow programmers to be smart enough to
not make this mistake but what if they
make it so we could generally handle for
it I'm not sure I would you might
actually want this to throw a pretty
hard error but let's say we wanted to
handle for that kind of an error as well
so let's say you've got a program that
you just want to run indefinitely so an
example of this is like a web parser so
I've got like a spider that crawls the
web for to parse news documents to
generate sentiment on anyways I want
that running all the time I never want
it to crash so I in case all of the code
in many versions of exception handling
because I want to I want to catch every
exception including ones I didn't even
think about and I want the code to
continue to run so how can we do that
well we can just add another exception
so here we could say except an index
error print that otherwise we can also
just accept and this is just a general
exception as e print something whoops
something went very wrong and then II
great okay now we could run this and
what happened oh we didn't pass okay so
try again
boom okay something went very wrong
function object is not scriptable okay
that makes a lot of sense and we've
handled for that error again you might
not actually want to hear it handle for
that specific type of error and you
might not want things to proceed if
someone made that error you might
actually want it to break and in which
case you could force it to break the
next thing and the only other thing I
want to bring up is that in try and
accept there are two more statements we
could pass you can have try except you
can have else and then you can also have
finally so these are two statements that
you'll pretty rarely see but especially
like with finally you will see this run
at the very end like if you're trying to
maintain a connection or something in
like some sort of i/o operation where if
you are to disconnect randomly midstream
it could cause a mess you would use
finally to kind of clean up the mess
before the script closes out or
something but just know those exist if
you want to learn more about them again
you got a friend in his name is Google
comm there are tons of tutorials on it I
even I have some try except else finally
tutorials you could search them on
YouTube or whatever just know those
exist and I just I hate to talk about
try and accept and not mention hey by
the way but they're very rare right I
rarely see people actually using them so
just know they exist okay so at this
point okay we've got some basic error
handling you can also cause certain
errors which we can talk about later but
to throw an error you you can also do
the following so we can here you can use
raise and this will raise a certain type
of exception and you can raise a very
specific one and so there will be times
or there could be times where you want
to purposely do that
anyway so that's it for air handling we
just wanted to have at least some basic
air handling for the doofuses that use
our program and now I think in the next
tutorial we are ready to start
determining who won the game so we know
how we can we know how we can modify
certain positions we don't yet have any
handling for if someone tries to play on
top of someone else's position but
that's pretty simple to do but the one
thing that we haven't covered yet how
could we do is how do we know when
someone is won how do we know when this
entire row is ones or twos or how do we
know when vertically these are all ones
or twos or diagonally this way or this
way how do we do that
so in the next tutorial we're going to
start talking about how do we determine
a winner then once we determine winners
we're just gonna be able to clean up
everything and end up with a mediocre
game of tic-tac-toe so with that I will
see you guys in the next video